[Music]
here's the top business news of the week
russia is openly threatening to cut off
gas supplies to europe that would lead
to enormous supply shortages especially
for germany but also for the rest of the
eu
many companies use gas for furnaces in
their production people hit with it and
power plants produce electricity with
gas
a sudden supply stop would cause energy
prices to increase dramatically
prices for oil and gas have already
increased consumers can see that every
day at the petrol stations
and on their gas bill
before the russian attack a megawatt
hour of gas cost 69 euros and was
considered expensive at the time
in the meantime the price has soared to
a record high of 335 euros
no one knows whether russia will enact
its threat and turn off the tap
completely
that's why the eu wants to become
independent of russian gas as quickly as
possible
repower eu is the new strategy it relies
on many different energy suppliers
including wind solar energy and
electricity from biogas
renewables give us the freedom to choose
an energy source
that is clean
cheap
reliable and ours
and instead of continuing to fund fossil
fuel imports
and fund russian oligarchs
renewables create new jobs here in
europe
by the end of the year the eu wants to
replace two-thirds of russian gas
imports
the war in ukraine shocked europe
now it's rapidly accelerating the eu's
energy transition toward greener energy
sources
[Music]
through the window of his office mayor
hans peter heskin looks out onto one of
europe's largest gas storage facilities
it's operated by a gazprom subsidiary in
the municipality of yemgum deep in
northern germany
the gas exports supply the kremlin with
revenue it can use for war
thousands of people are now dying in
this war and ultimately the war is being
financed by funds that are earned here
in germany maybe even right here in our
community so i don't think anyone here
in the community is still behind the
company
deep beneath the town lie salt domes
where the natural gas from russia is
being stored what particularly annoys
the mayor is that the volunteer fire
department has to ensure the safety of
the gasprom facility
it costs the town around a quarter of a
million euros a year
there has to be an agreement that the
operators of the gas caverns will share
in the costs in other words they'll
contribute 70 of the costs for
firefighting services we've calculated
this share on the basis of the hazard
potential
he's been negotiating with the gas from
subsidiary asteroid in castle for years
so far without any success
asteroid wind gas gascade and other gas
prompt subsidiaries operate the largest
gas storage facilities in germany
they also own important pipelines and
trade in russian natural gas
a murky corporate network
the municipalities also lose tax revenue
as a result
[Music]
all of a sudden through a reallocation
there was a change of name there was not
even a single tax sent
there's no way to reach out to those
responsible
it's been like that in the past so the
experience with gasprom was not a good
one here in the region
until now gasprom has been able to
operate freely on the market in germany
even building its own pipelines like
here in eastern germany only now with
the war on ukraine there's been a change
of thinking the state has been given
more control
we have an appointment with bill browder
at the ritz one of london's most swanky
addresses
he was once one of the most important
investors in russia but he quickly
became an opponent of vladimir putin and
was expelled from the country he's lived
in london for 16 years and is one of the
kremlin's biggest critics
britain has been a
soft spot for
dirty russian money for the last 20
years they've come here
they like the
rule of law they like the property
rights
and they like the fact that nobody's
going to ask any questions
with bill browder we visit eaton square
in the posh belgravia district nicknamed
red square the asking price for a
five-bedroom apartment here is more than
20 million euros and no one needs to
know who the real owner is
anti-corruption activists estimate that
russian oligarchs with ties to putin
have invested almost 2 billion euros in
real estate alone in recent years
there are shells shell companies and
trusts and and offshore trusts and
nominees and proxies all
working hard to shield the true
ownership of these properties
the city is known by some as london grad
because of the many wealthy russians who
live here not all of them have earned
their money honestly
this week the british parliament finally
passed a law to curb corrupt money flows
from russia to untangle complex
ownership structures but that's only a
first step experts say
legislation is just not enough
enforcement needs to be happen and it
needs to be properly funded and
resourced what happens right now is that
the national crime agency has been
underfunded for our generation so what
we need to see now is for law
enforcement agencies to be funded to act
now and use the tool that they are given
at the moment
critics ask whether it really took a war
in europe to cut off the wealthy
russians from their london playground
the world bank has approved a new aid
package for ukraine worth almost half a
billion dollars it is available
immediately the money can be used to pay
wages for hospital employees pensions
and social benefits
more and more western companies are
seizing operations in russia coca-cola
is joined by competitor pepsi starbucks
mcdonald's and kfc are also pulling out
of russia because of the attack on
ukraine and the least of companies
recalling their employees is also
growing longer with each passing day
motorists are feeling the pinch of the
ukraine war at the gas pumps but now car
manufacturers are also facing rising
prices for aluminum which is used to
build car bodies and for palladium which
is used in catalytic converters and for
nickel which is used in batteries
aluminum and palladium have both reached
record highs
nickel hit its highest level since 2007.
as a result cars and spare parts could
become more expensive
the european central bank intends to
take all necessary measures to ensure
the stability of the euro ecb president
christine lagarde said the interest rate
will remain untouched however the ecb is
accelerating its exit from stimulus
programs
inflation could rise further in the
short term she said as energy oil and
gas become much more expensive due to
the war
russia's invasion of ukraine is
accelerating plants by the eu to move
away from fossil fuels one project that
could play an important role in these
efforts is tesla's gigafactory in
brandenburg now that it's received final
environmental approval a long-awaited
milestone
this does not mean that all bureaucratic
hurdles have been cleared but the new
factory is nearing its opening
[Music]
any farmer who still has grain in
storage is now turning it into cash
rudolph peters a trader in northern
germany ships wheat to ports like
hamburg and rostock from there it heads
off to north africa
since it became clear that wheat
deliveries from ukraine one of the
world's largest wheat exporters would be
cancelled the managing director has been
inundated with inquiries despite the
high prices
depending on the daily fluctuations
wheat currently costs around 450 euros a
ton
then the goods have to be transported to
north africa to iran saudi arabia egypt
and algeria
there there are freight rates of 40 to
50 euros a ton so recipient countries
have to pay 500 euros a ton
ukraine has traditionally been one of
the world's largest wheat exporters with
many large farms
on the world market the country has
often competed with russia in recent
years
now because of the war the country can
no longer deliver there's a shortage of
employees fuel and seed people around
the world are feeling the loss
according to the latest world food
report we already have an increase in
malnourished people which is again
moving in the direction of a billion
people and it's feared that with this
commodity price explosion we're
experiencing a further increase in
malnutrition is to be expected
in this large flower mill they process
around a thousand tons of wheat a day
the fact that ukrainian wheat is in
short supply on markets around the world
has also been noticed by mill owner jan
cordesmeier he advocates producing less
meat in order to stabilize grain prices
and also secure food in poor countries
in germany we use about half of the
wheat produced to feed pigs and other
livestock to produce meat but now i can
only produce one kilo of meat from seven
kilos of grain this raises the question
of whether it still makes sense to grow
so much wheat for meat production
it'll be a long time before the next
grain harvest in europe and before the
warehouses fill up again
the lady m a luxury yacht worth around
65 million euros it was seized over the
weekend on the italian mediterranean
coast
the owner is alexay mordechov one of the
richest men in russia and a major
shareholder in the german tourism
company tui
yachts airplanes company shares and
luxury real estate abroad are considered
assets and therefore full under the
sanctions against the country
on the cote d'azur this mega yacht owned
by russian billionaire and putin
supporter igor sechin was also prevented
from sailing literally at the last
minute it's valued at around 120 million
euros
it was docked it was about to leave it
was a matter of hours we really did a
check on the people and we managed to
stop this ship and keep it docked
it belongs to a highly placed
personality in russia
the sanctions hit the richest russians
such as putin confidante and
entrepreneur alisher uzmanov
his luxury yacht one of the largest in
the world worth around 600 million euros
is in a shipyard in the port of hamburg
and could soon be seized
the u.s has also imposed sanctions on
usmanov and seven other putin-friendly
oligarchs
these include nikolai takarav the head
of energy giant transneft and
billionaire arkady rodenberg and his
brother
there are also visa restrictions on 19
other russian billionaires
the fbi is specifically looking for him
evgeny prygodzin
also known as putin's cook he runs a
catering company that serves meals to
the kremlin he is said to be one of the
founders of the wagner group a
paramilitary unit that recently sent 400
soldiers to try and assassinate
ukrainian president zielenski
thank you for watching